said in the hills behind Central Hong
Kong is a cities only explosive disposal
Depot managed by the police force it's
the last port of call for explosives and
devices considered too risky for other
emergency services to handle I think the
biggest surprise was was a large seizure
of TATP I think like that at the point
that that claim was unexpected to the
police just to see a homemade explosive
of that nature appearing in in Hong Kong
in that quantity TATP are explosive
chemicals often used to make homemade
bombs since the anti-government protests
began six months ago the bomb disposal
bureau says it's dealt with an
increasing number of explosives and raw
chemicals used to manufacture makeshift
weapons police say 10,000 petrol bombs
seized from the Polytechnic University
were detonated at the Depot this week I
don't think anybody would ever expect to
be dealing with 10,000 petrol bombs but
yes like that certainly that I don't
think I ever expect to be dealing with
petrol bombs it's in Hong Kong and
certainly to be dealing with 10,000 it
is is remarkable along with with the raw
materials that go with more than a
thousand protesters were arrested at
Polytechnic University after students
barricaded themselves up inside for
almost two weeks last month since the
siege ended at the Polytechnic
University this Depot has become the key
collection point the explosives found at
the campus but the team's head don't
just detonate they called up to clear
the sites where the explosives have been
made the protests were initially in
opposition to the extradition bill which
would have seen fugitives in Hong Kong
extradited to the mainland for trial the
proposed law was scrapped but the anger
has now morphed into an anti-government
movement demanding less control from
China's leaders in Beijing parts of Hong
Kong remain paralyzed by the recent
demonstrations
police say protesters destroyed more
than 700 traffic lights many are yet to
be repaired
police have condemned demonstrators as
radical rioters no democracy groups are
under pressure to do the same
but say the police are to blame they are
part of a movement we stand with each
other and we stay with them wherever the
escalation of the actions we see it was
always perfect and triggered by the
police use of unnecessary and excessive
force police have approved a
pro-democracy rally this Sunday it's
planned to mark the six-month
anniversary of demands for change and is
expected to attract a large crowd Sarah
Clark al Jazeera Hong Kong